look at this you're in purgatory welcome
friend exactly what you thought it would
be well lit and me here hi renews your
something's no no no you know your life
is different now the holidays are upon
us so I took it upon myself to give you
guys some ideas for DIY holiday gifts
that cover the spectrum of people that
you might need or feel guilt it into
giving gifts to this season and cost
minimal dollars and spoiler I genuinely
tried to make gifts that you could
actually give to people that would be
okay depending on who you're giving it
to I went on Pinterest and I found a
variety of ideas for DIY projects and I
sort of gave them my own twist a lot of
these worked out surprisingly well even
though they are incredibly dumb which is
all I could hope for even if you don't
like the specific gifts I base maybe you
can just pick up some of the skills and
interpret them as you will for gifts for
people that you love or hate or in
between so that forever do here is the
grace Helbig DIY holiday gift guide
transition
[Music]
[Applause]
tassel earrings those earrings that
people that are more confident than you
wear so why not make your own DIY
versions for them so that one they know
that you spend enough time alone to make
earrings and two let's not think about
what - could be I got this DIY from a
pair and a spare diy.com I'll link in
description box below and according to
this site for this DIY project you need
scissors six bundles of embroidery
thread whatever color that you prefer to
metal beads to earrings hook and a
needle and thread so according to a
parent of spare diy.com you want to
remove the embroidery thread from the
packaging and then you're gonna fold it
in half and tie it together but my
embroidery thread felt like there was a
lot in each packaging so I made an
executive decision to cut each my
bundles in half so that each bundle
would make two tassels from there just
gonna cut a couple of extra pieces of
embroidery strain to put to the side
you're gonna take half of your bundle
and you're just gonna tie it in half
cinch that waist then you're gonna cut
through any loops on either end of your
bundle then you're gonna fold your
bundle in half and tie another stray
piece of embroidery thread around the
top to make it look like a fun ghost or
a silly fabric octopus or a tiny voodoo
doll that you've had since the New
Orleans episode of a travel show you did
years ago but you're afraid to throw
away because you still kind of believe
that it might control the emotional
climate of your life and then trim up
any excess string to give it a clean
look and there you go you have the first
tassel in your tassel earrings they're
going to continue this step and make as
many tassels as you want per set of
earrings I'm making four per each
earring now we're gonna grab our needle
and thread and tie a knot at the end of
our thread and then push the needle
through the first tassel from the bottom
to the top add an extra stitch on top
just to keep it in place and then
continue threading
up through as many tassels as you want
per earring I did something a little
extra artistic with mine and I stitch
two tassels together at the top instead
of keeping them in a straight line once
you're done adding all of your tassels
thread on a gold bead and then use
needle and thread to tie and the tassels
to the earring hook full disclosure I
really tried to cut these into the shape
of dicks but they actually just turned
out kind of cute
[Music]
this is my tank on a gratitude jar which
if you don't know is a jar that you
write down things that you are grateful
for and you put them in the jar that's
all it is and one of them is on Oprah's
Favorite Things list for 2017 for $45 a
glass jar that says gratitude that you
put papers in so I decided to make my
own I got a glass jar and I found this
itching paint for glass at the craft
store so I decided I'm going to use that
too so we need a paintbrush and some
tape to tape off the area that we want
edged and some construction paper to
write down some feelings later on
according to this etching solution you
just tape off or use a stencil for
whatever area that you want H I just did
a ring around the jar and then you cover
the area with this solution for a few
minutes I did a couple different coats
because I had never used it before and
then you let it sit for a few minutes
and then you wash it off I only work
Jesus Christ it [ __ ] worked you guys
now you can decorate your jar however
you like I found these sticky glitter
letters at the craft store so I decided
to write on the outside exactly what
this bottle was and in fact it is
bottled up feelings that's right get the
[ __ ] out of here with your gratitude
this gift is for my repressed babies out
there so this is how this bottle works
we're gonna take our construction paper
and write down feelings or thoughts or
just like burning emotions that you have
about the person you're gonna give this
to that you would never say to their
face or that you've been harboring for
many many many years
once all your bottled up feelings are in
your bottle I put some cute little gold
star glitter in there to make it really
festive lock up the bottle and voila you
have a bottle of your feelings to give
someone this holiday season
[Music]
this one's a quickie but a good one it's
personalized denim jacket denim jackets
are really popular and you can get one
for really cheap especially this one I
got for free from Calvin Klein at VidCon
thank you not fun but like you're
sponsoring everyone else so and I have a
girl out you can get all sorts of uh
turn-on letters or patches from your
craft store
I got a few letters here to personalize
this jacket until I realized that they
don't iron onto denim very well so I'm
keeping with the messaging of the jacket
I've decided to hot glue them onto the
front of the jacket and while not you
have a personalized denim jacket that
the person you're gifting it to just can
never wash ever
[Music]
why buy a quirky notebook when you can
personalize one for a friend or loved
one or enemy I found a section of the
craft store that offered all these
supplies to build your own notebooks and
that's what we're doing right now I'm
using this hard cardboard as the cover
to my notebook and this matching natural
stock paper as the paper that goes
inside the notebook then after spending
15 solid minutes trying to get these two
goddamn gold spine rings apart from each
other we're gonna take one and thread
our notebook cover and paper on trip
we're gonna refer to an actual notebook
that we own that has a similar spine to
see that closing the spine is just as
simple as we think it is and that we're
not being an idiot and then all I have
to do is push the spine rings together
and slam dunk our notebook is put
together but now we're gonna personalize
it using more of these sticky glitter
letters on the front of it and wallah
you have a perfectly personalized
notebook to give that loved one whose
brain works bad this is a fun one I
found some air dried clay in the kids
craft section of the craft store and I
decided I'm going to sculpt a ring
holder for someone I love dearly me it's
hot I'm I'm gonna keep this one so I
need is a work surface and some water to
keep the clay wet so you can sculpt it
there's a lot of tutorials online that
show you how you can use bowls that you
already have in your house to make like
little dishes that can hold jewelry but
I decided I wanted to make something a
little bit more specific once you're
done molding your particular piece you
just leave it out to dry this can take a
few hours or you might want to leave it
overnight then you can paint it however
you want and while not you have a
perfectly personalized ring holder that
will give that loved one a very direct
message
[Music]
and that's it for my grades no big deal
holiday gift guide I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you make any of these
gifts for anyone that's in your life
human animal alive dead please tag me on
Instagram or Twitter and let me know
find out if you don't want to make
anyone I give this holiday season you
can just buy them a really cute
cost-effective pet owner charm necklace
set from my jewelry line link in the
description box below I'm wearing one of
the necklaces right now or you can
actually buy them a goose set my dog has
their own set of jewelry $20 link in the
description below I don't know if I
fully mentioned this on video yet but we
have two more pet owner holiday necklace
charm sets available on his best pitches
and the other is more dogs less people
less people more dogs go check it out
link is in the description box below if
you like this video give it a thumbs up
and don't forget to click that button
below and subscribe to this YouTube
channel I make videos never though I
want to now I don't know you okay one
more time look really confused